standing resilient for over a hundred
and fifty years
the dohanya street synagogue is one of
the largest jewish houses of worship on
the planet
this is hungary's great synagogue
[Music]
the synagogue was constructed in the
1850s its architect settled on a
distinctly moorish look in the
building's design combining elements of
north african and central european
architecture inside this monumental
space is a capacity for nearly 3 000
worshipers making it the largest
synagogue in europe and one of the
largest working synagogues in the world
the synagogue has hosted concerts with
classical legends like franz liszt and
in modern times the chamber still fills
to standing room only for performances
but it wasn't always celebrations behind
these walls
the building suffered and survived
bombings and occupation by the nazis and
it was heavily damaged when the soviet
union retook the city near the end of
world war ii
the story of the synagogue's worshippers
and the jews of europe at large is
preserved throughout the complex
it is home to a jewish museum a jewish
cemetery and a sobering memorial to the
atrocities of the holocaust
this great synagogue both reminds us of
darkness and inspires us to hope as we
look forward into the future
[Music]
you